So, your connection is good? Uh,
>> I think so. Um, is it okay? Yeah,
>> there's an echo, but I can live with it
as long as you can hear.
So, how old are you?
>> I'm um 20.
>> All right. How long you become a Muslim?
>> I've been a Muslim for one and a half
months.
>> Yeah. Recent, huh? And that's because of
college. You're in college. Not to give
away your location.
>> Yeah, I'm in college now. Yeah. And
that's how you encountered Islam. Sorry,
I'm just getting some drink from my
throat.
>> Yeah, I heard heard about it for the
first time through uh through friends
and stuff. Um through neighbors
>> neighbors, but not on campus.
>> On on campus? Yes. Well, not not through
classes or anything. Just just
neighbors. Yep.
>> Okay. So,
>> yeah.
>> Cuz I saw your sign you had Muslim
Student Association. What's the
connection with that?
>> Yeah. Um I mean I joined the Muslim
Student Association just like there's
Christian organizations.
>> So okay. So then you left uh
Catholicism. I'm assuming that's what it
was.
>> Yes sir.
>> How how well catechized you were in the
Catholic faith.
>> Um I mean you can ask me some questions.
I I think I was pretty well catechized
but my mom says you know I should go to
go to school to study scripture. I don't
know.
>> Well catechized. So if if you're will
catechized when a Muslim ask you the
basic questions that they do like where
did Jesus say I am God. Were you asked
that question?
>> I I was asked that question. Yeah. And I
said I referred to the gospel of John
and also the end of the gospel of
Matthew.
>> And how did you answer? What did you
show them?
>> I I showed them those those verses
especially you know John 3:16. God sent
his only son. I showed um I showed a
sentiment you know baptizing them in the
name of the father and son holy spirit.
>> Yeah. John is not Jesus saying he's God
because they're going to sell you.
>> Okay. Yeah, you're right. I am the
alpha, the omega, the beginning, and the
end. That's a better one maybe.
>> So when you you did quote that to them,
alpha and omega.
>> Yeah.
>> And so what convinced you that to change
your position? If you're telling me that
Jesus claimed to be alpha and omega,
then why did you change?
>> Corruption of the scriptures.
>> Even the Quran says the Bible is
uncorrupt and it's the judge of
Muhammad. You know this, right?
>> It doesn't say that. So, what verse in
the Quran were you going to point to to
show me that the Quran says the Bible's
corrupt? There is none, but I want to
see what they talk.
>> So, so I I don't have a I don't have one
to um to show right now, but I was uh
the the one that William uh he would he
was making his whole argument that um
that we need to judge or what was it
called? I can't find my words now, but
>> yes, I know. Was he referring to 547?
and the Christians are to judge by the
>> I don't know.
>> Yes. Well, the Quran, one of the proofs
that the Quran gives that Muhammad is a
prophet is that he supposedly confirms
the scriptures and the possession of the
Jews and Christians.
So, one of the tests to know whether
Muhammad is a prophet, I'm going to give
you the verses. I'm going to give you
the receipts. And you talk about being a
but you ignore the fact that the Quran
says that his contemporary said he's
majun he's a mad man he's a liar. So
we're going to go into that step by step
because I saw you appealed to Al
supposedly that he was the trustworthy
which again they deceived you but I I'll
get there. Let's take it step by step. I
don't want to over
>> first of all the proof the Quran itself
gives that it's true. It supposedly
confirms the Bible and agrees with the
Bible. That's the test it gives. And I'm
going to give you the receipts. And this
makes sense because even Jesus in the
New Testament and the apostles who
preached always had to appeal to the Old
Testament to say we confirm the Old
Testament. The Old Testament points to
Jesus and his message
because those who were given the
scriptures before Jesus showed up on
earth
knew that a prophet cannot contra
contradict the revelations already
established already given. And because
of that Jesus and his followers are
constantly appealing to the Old
Testament saying this is God's
revelation.
These revelations already prophesied my
coming and I'm fulfilling it. The same
thing your prophet did. That's my point.
That's why you appealed to the pariclete
passages because your prophet knew that
he cannot be a true prophet if he
contradicts the revelations of the
prophets that came before him. He has to
confirm them. And which is why he even
says they announce my coming. None of
which is true because in chapter 7 157
of the Quran it says that they will find
mention of the unlettered prophet in the
Torah the gospel that is with them. Let
me show you that verse. Let me show it
here and I'll go through it
systematically because I want to help
you because I know they told you the
Quran says the Bible's corrupt. That's a
lie. And that the Quran is the judge
over the Bible. That's a lie. I I know
this man. I've heard it cuz I too when I
was young had a Muslim use objections
that I wasn't prepared for. But I didn't
jump and leave Christianity unlike you.
I went and found the answers and saw
their lies. Now, I'm not saying your
Muslim friends lied to you. They just
don't know any better. They've been
deceived. But what I want to ask you is
this. This is talking about the time of
Muhammad.
7157. It's on the screen. I'm going to
enlarge it. And it's saying that they're
going to find a prophecy of the apostle,
the unlettered prophet um in the law and
the gospel that's with them whom they
find mentioned their own scriptures in
the law and the gospel. Now if you
cannot show me what gospel was with them
and where this prophecy is, then you're
saying the Quran is a lie because
Muhammad is saying it exists at his
time. So what existed at his time?
>> Yeah. So, so I have uh there are a
couple other arguments too. I know um
John the Baptist, they they mention um
are you are you uh Elijah? Are you um
are you the Messiah or are you the
prophet?
>> You sure you want to hear?
>> You should
I want to hear the argument. Yeah.
>> Now, watch what you just did because I
want to show you the prophecy in
context.
Watch what you just did. Okay. You just
proved Muhammad is an antichrist. You're
going to have to come back to the
Catholic Church because this is the
prophecy you're referring to. John 1:19.
And this is the witness of John when the
Jews sent to him priests and Levites
from Jerusalem to ask him, "Who are
you?" And he confessed and did not deny,
but confessed, "I'm not the Christ." And
they asked him, "What then? Are you
Elijah?" And he said, "I am not." "Are
you the prophet?" See, this is what
you're referring to, right? I know what
you're referring to, but this is the
one, right?
Right. Okay. You lost connection, I
guess. Are you back? Are you back,
brother?
Yes. Connection is bad.
>> Yeah. Pray guys. The connection he's lo
Okay. Are you back?
>> Hey, I'm sorry. I'm back.
>> Okay. Now, did you catch it? So, right
here, this is what you're referring to
when they asked him, "Are you the
Christ?" No. Elijah, no. Are you the
prophet? Right.
>> Mhm.
>> That's the one you're referring to,
right? To John the Baptist.
>> Okay.
>> Yes.
>> Now, okay. Now, conveniently, this is
now going to prove Muhammad is an
antichrist for two reasons. First of
all, let me first finish what John says
and then I'm going to come back and ask
you a question. What then? Are you
Elijah? And he said, I'm not. Are you
the prophet? And he answered, no.
Therefore, they said to him, who are
you? So that we may give an answer to
those sent us. What do you say about
yourself? He said, I am a voice of one
crying in the wilderness. Make straight
the way of the Lord, as Isaiah the
prophet said. So I'll get back to this,
but I want you to notice this is what
you quoted. This is the same chapter,
same section.
Now they had been sent from the
Pharisees, and they asked him and said
to him, "Why then are you baptizing if
you're not the Christ, nor Elijah, nor
the prophet, John answered them, saying,
I baptize with water, but among you
stands one whom you do not know." So
he's already here. He stands among you,
but you don't know him. This one is he
after me, of whom I am not worthy to
untie the strap of his handle. These
things took place in Bethany beyond the
Jordan and where John was baptizing.
Now, who is this one? Here you go. On
the next day, he saw Jesus, not
Muhammad, coming to him and said,
"Behold the lamb of God who takes away
the sin of the world. This is he of whom
I said, after me comes a man who has
been ahead of me, for he existed before
me. I did not know him, but so that he
might be manifest Israel. I came
baptizing with water and John bore
witness saying I have beheld the spirit
descending as a dove out of heaven and
he abided on him and I did not know him
but he who sent me to baptize with water
said to me the one upon whom you see the
spirit descending and abiding upon him
this is the one who baptized holy spirit
and I myself have seen and have borne
witness that this is son of god you just
appealed to this section when in its
entirety it shows Muhammad is an
antichrist Because do you believe Jesus
is the son of God?
>> I see.
>> Do you believe he's the lamb of God who
takes away the sin of the world?
>> No.
>> But John the Baptist does. Which means
John the Baptist said, "Your prophet is
in hell because he contradicts what the
Baptist taught about Jesus." So why did
you appeal to this chapter?
>> Ignorance, I guess. Yeah,
>> exactly. You just said it.
>> Yeah. Okay, never mind.
>> Muslims know you're ignorant. They play
it on you. But now, let me show you how
bad this is. You're saying that the
prophet is Muhammad, right?
>> It could be.
>> How can it be, is Muhammad an an
Israelite or is he an Arab?
>> Arab.
>> So, why did they ask an Israelite if
he's the prophet if they were expecting
an Arab prophet? Because who did they
ask? Are you the prophet? Did they ask
an Arab or an Israelite? They were
asking they were expecting a brother of
the of the Israelites.
>> No, you didn't hear what I said. Who did
they ask here? Are you the prophet? Who
>> did they ask? You're not listening. So,
you're pretending because you're
following the
>> John the Baptist.
>> Is John the Baptist an Arab or an
Israelite?
>> Israelite.
>> So, you just proved Muhammad can't be
the prophet because they're expecting an
Israelite. That's why they asked an
Israelite, "Are you the prophet?" So,
why did you misquote this?
the the who who were they expecting? I
mean, it did did it
>> whatever they expect.
>> Do we know for sure that it was an
Israelite or a Arab or could it just be
anyone?
>> You appealed to this. I didn't appeal to
it. So now you're saying they're wrong.
So why did you quote them if they're
wrong? Because they're the ones saying,
"Hey, you Israelite, are you that
prophet?" That means the people you
appeal to, so you're not listening to
yourself. The people you appeal to did
not expect the prophet to be an Arab.
They expected it to be an Israelite,
which means they just proved Muhammad is
an antichrist. But now you're saying
they're wrong. So why did you appeal to
them?
>> I mean, how did they know it was going
to be an Israelite?
>> You're the one who appealed to them. So
are you saying they're wrong?
>> Well, they could be expecting either,
you know, an Israelite or someone else.
No, they told an Israelite, not an Arab.
Are you the prophet? The Jews, they went
to an Israelite, which means they
expected the prophet to be an Israelite.
If they're right, Muhammad is an
antichrist. So, are they right or are
they wrong? You appeal to them. I didn't
appeal to them because if the Jews are
right, the prophet is someone else than
the Christ, then they're also right. He
can't be an Arab. So, your prophet is in
hell. So, coming back to the issue, the
Quran says the Bible's corrupt. I can go
through that. But you want to talk about
the character of Muhammad.
>> Is that what you wanted to do? Because I
can go to any topic.
>> All right. But so if your prophet was g
receiving revelation from the same
source, God, same angel Gabriel, why is
it that the hadith say that the spirit
violated Muhammad, squeezed him three
times to the point Muhammad thought he
was going to die and then ran trembling
with fear, begging his wife to cover
him, and when the spirit wouldn't show
up, he'd get depressed and want. How
come his experience is unlike the
experience of the true prophets of God?
Because the true prophets of God when
they saw the angel, they're afraid. The
angels say, "Do not be afraid." When
they saw Christ and his risen glorified
majesty, do not be afraid. But this
spirit made Muhammad very afraid to the
point it
took his wife and her cousin to convince
him he's not demonpossessed.
Gotcha.
>> Because it wasn't the Gabriel that
appeared to Muhammad. And let me give
you the receipt so you don't think I'm
lying. In fact, do you know according to
Jesus, Muhammad's symptoms is a sign of
demon possession. He exemplified the
same symptoms that someone
demonpossessed exemplifies. Let me show
it to you. Here you go. I'm going to
give you the receipts and I'm going to
show you that according to the Bible,
these are the symptoms that someone has
when he's demonpossessed.
So here you go in private chat right
here. Now watch here. This is again from
Muslim sources. Bkari. All right. I want
you to see his symptoms. Okay. So I give
you a link where you can find it. Some
of them they're not online. You got to
get the books. But here,
>> right?
>> Okay. Narrated Safwan Bin Yala bin from
his father who said a man came to the
prophet while he was at Jirana. The man
was wearing a cloak which had traces of
kaluk or sufra. The man asked the
prophet, "What do you order me to
perform perform in my umrah?" So Allah
inspired the prophet, this is when he's
receiving revelation. And he was
screened by a place of cloth. I wish to
see the prophet being divinely inspired.
Umar said to me, "Come, you will be
pleased to look at the prophet while
Allah is inspiring him." Now watch. I
replied in affirmative. Umar lifted one
corner of the cloth and I looked at the
prophet who was snoring. Snoring like
that of a camel.
Interesting. Show me any prophet that
went through these kind of physical
experiences. But here's another one.
This comes from Im Jalal Abdman Ali, the
perfect guide to the sciences of the
Quran
Quran volume on page 104.
S related that Aisha said whenever the
prophet received inspiration, his head
would twitch. He would foam
at the sides of his mouth. Okay, that's
another symptom. Snore like a camel
from
the life of the prophet Muhammad al
volume 1 page 307. Omar said to me,
would you like to look at the messenger
of God while revelation is coming to
him? He raised the edge of his robe from
his face while he was receiving
revelation at Aljana and he was all
flushed and he would moan like a newborn
calf.
All right, not going to belabor the
point here. Even on a cold day, Sah
Bkari volume one number two, it says
that he would hear the revelation like
the ringing of a bell.
And this would hurt his ears. It says
right here,
"Verily, I saw the prophet being
inspired divinely on a very cold day and
noticed the sweat dropping from his
forehead." Again, Sal Bkari volume 3
book 48 number 828. So there overtook
him the state which used to overtake him
where he used to have on being inspired
divinely. He was sweating so much so
that the drops of the sweat were
dropping like pearls though it was cold
wintry day. So he would sweat profusely
moan like a camel foam at the mouth.
Right? What else? He would get a
headache. Ib kir life of the prophet
Muhammad and he would faint
al
faint notice faint fall down snore like
a camel
sweat profusely foam at his mouth now
let me show you on top of that bkari the
prophet's face was red and he kept on
breathing breathing heavily for a while
and then was revealed. Salkari volume 6
number 58. According to the Bible,
that's the symptom of a demon-possessed
man. Mark 9:14 and 27. When a
demon-possessed man was brought to
Jesus, look at the symptoms. Teacher, I
brought you Mark 9:14-27.
I brought you my son who was a mute
spirit. Wherever it takes hold on him,
it dashes him to the ground. He foams at
the mouth and nashes with his teeth and
becomes rigid.
When he saw him, immediately the spirit
dashed him and he fell on the ground and
wallowed foaming at the mouth. Why is it
your prophet has the symptoms of someone
demonpossessed?
And what did Jesus do? He rebuked the
foul spirit,
saying to it, you mute and deaf spirit,
I command you to come out of him and
enter him no more. The spirit cried out
and convulsed him greatly, but it came
out of him and he was dead. Why is it
your prophet has the symptoms of someone
demonpossessed,
not someone inspired by the spirit of
God?
And what did Muhammad say the spirit
would do to him? Here you go. Right
here. Salkari,
I'm giving you seeds, buddy. You've been
deceived. Sal Bkari, here you go. When
the spirit came to him black and white
narisha the commencement of the divine
inspiration to Allah's apostle was in
the form of good righteous dreams in
asleep he never had a dream but that it
came true like bright daylight he used
to go in seclusion
vra where he used to worship continually
continuously for many nights now the
words in parentheses they've added but
that's okay he used to take with him the
journey food for that stay and then come
back to his wife Khadijah to take his
food likewise again for another period
to stay till suddenly the truth
descended upon him while he was in the
cave of Haidra. The angel came to him
and in it and asked him to read the
prophet I do not know how to read read
now look the angel caught me forcefully
and pressed me so hard that I could not
bear it anymore. He then released me
again and asked me to read and I replied
I do not know how to read. whereupon he
caught me again and pressed me a second
time till I could not bear it anymore.
Let me ask you a side question before I
finish this.
>> Why the angel torturing Muhammad
when he tells him, "I don't know how to
read." Didn't Allah know Muhammad
doesn't know how to read? So why is he
having the angel ask him to read? And
when he says, "I can't read." And then
he brutalizes him to the point he is
stricken with horror and terror.
Why is your God doing this to your
prophet?
So what kind of God does this to someone
supposedly he loves? He then released me
and asked me again to read. But again I
replied three times. Huh? So the angel
didn't get it the first time? I don't
know how to read. Why are you torturing
me? I do not know how to read or what
shall I read? Thereupon he caught me for
the first time, pressed me and then
released me and then then said and
finally then he tells him okay repeat
after me. Why did he do it from the
beginning?
Why torture him three times and cause
this?
Then Allah's apostle return with
inspiration, his neck muscles twitching
with terror.
We will all become Muslim and take
shahada. If you show us any true prophet
of God who was violated to the point
where their neck was twitching with
terror, horrified, terrified, wanting to
kill them, kill themselves after they
encountered an angel from God.
you won't find it because that's not
what happened to them. Then turned upon
Khadijah and said, "Cover me. Cover me."
They covered him till his fear was over.
And then he said, "Oh, Khadijah, what is
wrong with me?" See, he thinks he's
nuts. He was right. He was
demonpossessed. Then he told her
everything that had happened and said,
"I fear that something may happen to
me." He was right. Now but after a few
days
the one he went to to ask him what's
happening to me who was a Christian who
used to read the gospel he goes if what
you tell me is true then came to you but
died he didn't live long enough to see
what the revelation was but when died
look what happened to your prophet the
divine inspiration was also paused for a
while and the prophet became so sad as
we have heard that he intended several
times s to throw himself from the tops
of the high mountains. And every time he
went up the top of a mountain in order
to throw himself down, Gabriel would
appear before him and say, "Oh,
Muhammad, you are indeed Allah's apostle
in truth." Whereupon his heart would
become quiet. He would calm down and
then he would freak out again. Whenever
the period of the coming of the
inspiration used to become long, he
would do as before. But when he used to
reach the top of a mountain, Gabriel
would show up. I will give you $10
million.
Okay? I'm going to give you 10 million
bucks and we'll all become Muslim. Show
me in your Quran or in the Bible any
prophet
that went through this torture and hell
and were frightened and wanted to after
crowning Gabriel.
>> Gotcha.
Well, I hope you got me because I don't
know why you're still a Muslim after
this. So, why are you a Muslim?
>> All right. I believe in one God, the
father almighty, creator of heaven and
earth. I believe in Jesus Christ, his
only son, our Lord, was conceived by the
power of the Holy Spirit, born of the
Virgin Mary, suffered under Pontious,
crucified, died, was buried. He he
descended into hell.
>> On the third day, he rose again from the
dead. He ascended into heaven, seated at
the right hand of the father.
He will come again to judge at the
beginning of the day.
>> Amen.
>> I believe in the Holy Spirit, the Holy
Catholic Church, the communion of
saints, the forgiveness of sins, the
resurrection of the body, and life
everlasting.
>> Hallelujah, brother. You're going to
make me cry.
We're proud of you, young man. You're
back home.
You're going to make me cry, man. You're
going to make me cry. Welcome home.
Welcome home, son.
We miss you. Now, I want you to call
your father. Tell him I made a mistake.
I've come back. I need to go back to the
priest and confess.
Welcome home, son.
So, you bear witness. Jesus is your
Lord, God, and Savior, right?
>> Yes, sir.
>> You say it. Jesus is my Lord, God, and
Savior.
>> Jesus is my Lord, God, and Savior.
>> We love you, Lucas. I love you, young
man. Go back and watch. And now, go read
our articles and videos. come home to
the Catholic church from which you were
born. You were baptized and call your
dad. Say, "Dad, I'm home.
I've returned to Jesus." Thank you, my
queen. I actually asked the holy mother
to intercede for you before I began. I
said, "Theotocos, please pray for this
young man. Your mother prayed for you.
The virgin, the Theotocos loves you. She
prayed to her son and the spirit brought
you home. We love you, Lucas."
>> All right. Thank you. Take care. God
bless you.
>> All right. He's home.
Okay, brethren.
I'm about to cry, man.
I'm about to cry. All right, that's it
for tonight.
I'll end it here. We won't spoil it.